Hello CZsWorld,
I know this isn't the type of content you
would usually expect from me, but I'm feeling
kind of experimental right now, so let me
know if this is something you'd like to see
from me in this poll right here, and don't
worry, this doesn't count as my video for
this week, just something I thought I'd try
out.
So here we see the Death Note falling into
the human world as it should, the one difference
being that it falls into an area where Light
is sitting by himself, as opposed to in the
anime where he just notices it fall past the
window and happens to be the first one to
pick it up.
So what's the difference?
In this film, you could say that the Shinigami
who dropped it is giving it to Light on purpose,
knowing full-well what he is capable of doing
with it.
You'll notice that the Death Note itself has
some strange new markings on the top corners.
This could be something as simple as the book
having been removed from the chain that Ryuk
uses to sling it around his shoulder.
That would mean that in this movie, Light
actually has Ryuk's Death Note, whereas in
the anime, he has the Death Note that Ryuk
stole from Sidoh.
So Ryuk may not have multiple notebooks in
this version.
Here he is.
Here's Ryuk.
Looks great in this light.
No pun intended.
Gods of Death love apples, and here we see
an apple moving on it's own, but also other
objects in this room swirling around.
I can't say for sure if the presence of a
Shinigami is what is causing that swirling,
but I will say that if it is, it could be
even more of a security threat to Light.
In the anime he had to worry about Ryuk simply
picking up and eating apple on camera, as
it would appear like a floating apple that
disappears to the naked eye, but this swirling
phenomenon could prove to be much more of
a distraction.
OK, so the film takes place in Seattle because
this is an American version of Death Note,
but why Seattle as opposed to any other American
city?
My theory is that it's the most reminiscent
of Tokyo.
Both cities feature a tall skinny observation
tower.
In Seattle it's the Space Needle.
In Tokyo, it's Tokyo Tower.
Both have a Ferris Wheel on their skyline
as well.
As you'll see later, the Ferris Wheel comes
into play in the plot somehow.
I couldn't find any real high schools abbreviated
with the letters NSH in Seattle, but let me
know if you can find any in the comments.
What's interesting here is that this girl
on the right looks more like Misa Amane, mostly
just because of her hair, but this girl in
the middle looks to be an actress named Margaret
Qualley.
According to IMDb, she's playing a character
named Mia Sutton.
Misa, Mia S...
It seems like Mia may be the American counterpart.
It would also seem that she is a little bit
younger if she's still in high school and
she probably isn't a celebrity any more, maybe
just a popular cheerleader instead.
Also she smokes now.
Unless that's Matt, and they've turned him
female for this movie...
Just kidding.
It's hard to tell from this lighting, but
it looks like this guy might be Lakeith Stanfield,
the actor who's playing L. If so, this is
a big departure from the usual white-shirt
and blue jeans L we are used to.
He's also wearing this mask that covers half
of his face, which could be paired with a
visor or glasses of some sort to protect his
identity.
As you probably know, Kira needs a name and
a face to kill someone using the Death Note.
On Light's desk, we see another apple and
some kind of little propeller based machine,
maybe a drone of some kind.
This tells us not only that Light is still
a genius in this adaptation, but also could
foreshadow the use of a helicopter later,
which if you've seen the show, you know that
one of the most pivotal turning points in
the series takes place while Light is in a
helicopter.
In this shot we learn that Light is left-handed,
as opposed to him being right-handed in the
series and the Japanese adaptations.
That makes me wonder if this will be used
against him in this movie.
If you aren't aware, left-handed writers tend
to run their hand against the page when writing
in English or any other language that goes
from left to right and as a result their hand
smudges against the text that they have just
written.
L could use this to determine that Kira is
left handed if he were to obtain the notebook.
This also narrows down the search a lot, considering
most people are right-handed.
This area has the same red lighting as the
area where we saw L walking before, meaning
that L may actually be investigating the scene
of the crime himself.
This, once again goes against what we are
accustomed to with L's character.
In the light novel The Los Angeles BB Murder
Cases, we learn that L likes to work behind
the scenes and sends Naomi Misora to do the
physical investigation for him.
We also see the name Kira being used, which
is noteworthy considering the characters have
been given Americanized names, like Light
Turner instead of Light Yagami and Mia Sutton
instead of Misa Amane.
But in the anime, the name Kira originates
from the Japanese pronunciation of the English
word "Killer", so perhaps Japan does play
some part in this movie after all.
In the anime, Kira does occasionally leave
little calling cards or false clues to L when
he kills criminals, but for the most part
just leaves the media to come up with the
idea of Kira on their own.
This message on the wall seems much more blatant.
Here's this girl again, and if this is her
making out with Light, then there is a good
chance that she is in fact supposed to be
Misa.
Unless of course, director Adam Wingard is
just throwing us a curveball and that is actually
Kiyomi Takada, which would make some sense
because of the fact that Light meets her in
college in the anime so he could just be meeting
her in high school in this film.
Towards the end of the trailer we see this
Ferris Wheel getting crushed and Light seems
to be saving someone.
This leads me to ponder a few possibilities.
Is this a part of one of Light's plans, much
like how he causes the catastrophe on the
bus to learn more about Raye Penber?
Is this the work of a Shinigami trying to
get their Death Note back?
I only suggest this because of the way the
Ferris Wheels bends in, as if an invisible
force is crushing it.
And one more possibility is that someone else
has a Death Note and they are trying to kill
someone on the Ferris Wheel or send a message
to Light.
Let me know what you think in the comments
below.
And don't forget to weigh in on if you liked
this type of video.
If you're new to CZsWorld and you love Death
Note then please consider subscribing to the
channel.
I'm a filmmaker and I love to make psychological
horror content so it should be right up your
alley.
I've got new horrors every other week, so
ring that death bell for notifications and
I'll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.